the mayor of New York City I believe is
is a thug and he sent his people here
today they had an organized text uh
alert that went out calling what I would
say antifa to bring their whistles pots
and pans all kinds of instruments to
make they brought pots and pans and they
almost started making a souffle all
kinds of noise to drown me out and drown
others here today that are protesting
and here supporting president Trump the
mayor of New York City mayor Adams owes
me an apology you know the really funny
thing was the guy handing out the
whistles was actually reported to be a
trump supporter so like the idea that it
was the left that organized the whistle
protest I I guess a trump supporter
thought that by handing out whistles
they would be able to drown out the
anti-trump protesters across the street
but all it actually did was drown out
Marjory Taylor green